hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcasts integration of the
simplex SC difícil direct assay in a
two-step algorithm for the laboratory
diagnosis of C difficile presented by
dr. james Neider professor of pathology
and laboratory medicine at University of
Louisville we are excited to bring you
this educational webcast
presented by Lavery and sponsored by GI
Sauron for more information please visit
WWE so I am I am Marjorie Taurus of lab
routes and I'll be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation and the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining a credit please join me in
welcoming dr. James NIDA I will now turn
the presentation over to him well thank
you very much and welcome to each and
every one of you who are participating
today
and we're going to discuss a topic that
is the best controversial but at least
timely and we're going to be dealing
with an infectious disease that's
getting a considerable prominence I'd
like to also thank the essaouira and
elaborate or sponsoring
as well as providing the opportunity to
discuss what I consider a hot topic with
you today by way of disclosure dia
Sauron has supported this particular
evaluation that was conducted in our
facility in addition to providing an
honor area before we move into the
actual presentation itself I want to
bring to your attention two very
important papers although the literature
is is quite large regarding c.difficile
testing and as a result I want to call
your attention to two recent papers that
are well worth your time to read and
strongly recommend that you take the
opportunity to review these papers the
first paper is by Fang and others in the
journal clinical microbiology
specifically buying 55 of this year 2017
pages 672 680 this paper is a
point-counterpoint paper entitled what
is the optimal approach for detection of
C difficile infection the other paper is
by Co Celia
ko CIO le ke also appeared in the
journal clinical microbiology of this
year pages 12 44 12:48 both of those
papers are in volume 55 and essentially
the lighter paper is discussing or
stressed the importance of risk based
testing to more preferably utilize
testing for Clostridium difficile next
slide please
this is a photo of our academic medical
center known as a University of
Louisville hospital it serves as the
primary teaching hospital for the
University of Louisville School of
Medicine
it is a 350 bed facility it is analogous
to the county or General Hospital but it
is a level 1
the center and our laboratory is the
core laboratory for one other
institution in the city here as a result
of that with the core laboratory going
active about 10 months ago our testing
volume including our c difficile testing
as currently triple the next slide by
way of objectives although the primary
focus of this presentation is to share
with you our experience in assessing the
performance of the simplex c difficile
direct assay I think it's important that
we summarize some of the epidemiology
the overall incidence of C difficile
infection including the financial burden
some mortality statistics and the
current extent of the problem we will
also characterize the organism itself
Australian difficile obviously discuss
with you the various testing approaches
and technologies that are available
today review the evaluation design that
was conducted in this laboratory discuss
the results and then make some
concluding remarks I will be using terms
such as mat which stands for nucleic
acid amplification testing sometimes
we'll use molecular assays but mat is
the common term and there's two schools
of thought as most of you are aware
today in terms of the laboratory testing
direct molecular or not testing or
algorithmic based we will be discussing
the pros and cons of each and hopefully
we'll bring you up to date as to
allowing you to make your own decision
or reinforcing the decision that you
already made with regards to testing in
your
facility next slide please
in terms of epidemiology currently C
difficile infection is one if not the
leading cause of infectious diarrhea in
the United States health care
environment accounts for approximately
15 to 25 percent of infectious diarrhea
reported in the US and to the CDC
there's approximately four hundred
fifty-three thousand cases combined with
29,000 deaths annually and the case or
the cost per case is ranging anywhere
from nine thousand to thirteen thousand
dollars quite expensive it's caused by
the organism known as clustering
difficile clustering difficile is a gram
positive anaerobic bacterium and two
separate strains are unique to C
difficile
obviously C difficile is a sporulating
organism so we have the spore phase
versus the vegetative stage also the
toxigenic and nontoxigenic strain our
president as well and these play a key
role in the disease process it's either
the toxigenic strain over the
nontoxigenic strain and this will relate
to some of the limitations of testing
that currently are utilized in the
laboratory the organism produces two
toxins toxin a toxin B and there is a
binary toxin known as na p1 or o 27 or
bi this is the binary toxin far more
virulent than the respective toxin B
toxin a so the binary toxin although
it's rare one of the deficiencies in our
current testing
is that either a conventional testing or
molecular testing does not specifically
test for binary Thompson but I will
mention in one of the technologies that
were including this evaluation it does
have the capability of detecting what
appears to be the binary toxin obviously
C difficile has increased worldwide and
it's a problem knowing the US but
throughout the world
the u.s. cost alone is approximately 500
million to 1.5 billion dollars a huge
absorbent cost due to this organism C
difficile we'll move to the next slide
want to briefly go over the laboratory
diagnosis of this particular organism
and stress the conventional methods
versus the current molecular methods I'm
not going to go into all the commercial
available molecular methods but stress
their basis of operation so when we talk
about conventional methods the first
thing to come to mind are the toxigenic
culture and the cell culture
cytotoxicity or sometimes referred to as
a cell cytotoxicity neutralization assay
it's important to know that the
toxigenic culture is exactly that it is
intended to recover Clostridium
difficile and to determine whether or
not if the isolate is a production or
produces toxin we take the supernatant
from the broad culture so we take it off
the plate place it into broth and allow
to incubate and use the supernatant to
determine whether it's a toxin producing
strain and we would do that with the
cell culture sign of cytotoxicity
utilization assay which obviously
detects toxin so the two tests are
regarded as gold Stan
when when comparing or evaluating
different assays but both are
labor-intensive and both have a longer
turnaround time and as a result of that
are not commonly used in clinical
laboratories because of those exact
reasons once again labor-intensive and a
longer turnaround time we have enzyme
immunoassay has become available over
the years and the two particular areas
of interest in enzyme immunoassay
testing are the glutamate dehydrogenase
test and the toxin detection pass a
toxin a and B glutamate dehydrogenase is
expressed by both toxigenic and
nontoxigenic strain of c difficile it's
it's produced and secreted extracellular
ly by vegetative cells this assay is is
believed and has been described as being
more sensitive than toxin assays but
both the gdh and toxin are screening
tests specifically the gdh is used
primarily as the screen which indicates
that if you get a positive gdh it
requires further testing using either a
toxin EIA
or possibly a molecular assay most
samples containing toxigenic c difficile
that have been detected by either
toxigenic culture or molecular assays
are commonly posited by the G DHEA and
most samples with detective detectable
toxin are also positive for GD H rarely
but it does occur and we have one
incidence and the evaluation I will
share with you there being a low
concentration will get a encounter or
the positive molecular assay with a
negative GD H
as I said that rarely occurs but it does
occur we need to look out for that and
as a result its most likely due to there
being a low concentration of the
organism C difficile and no toxin being
produced which is suggestive of the
carrier state or possibly patients that
are on therapy therefore the overall
sensitivity of GBA HDI a is
approximately 90% however some studies
report that gdh assays will miss up to
20% of specimens that are detected as
positives by nucleic acid testing once
again a debate between the two schools
of thought that is direct PCR versus
algorithm approach but the GD Agia is
somewhat less sensitive than a molecular
assay which is not surprising given the
nature of molecular assays now toxigenic
culture which detects both spores and
vegetative cells is important to keep in
mind as well so when you're doing the
toxigenic culture you may obtain either
toxigenic strain or nontoxigenic that's
why you have to confirm the presence of
toxin by using the cell cytotoxicity
neutralization assay when compared with
cytotoxin neutralization assay as well
as toxigenic culture gdh assays are
generally regarded as slightly less
sensitive and based upon a recent
meta-analysis in which the sensitivities
generated were pooled there respectively
was 94 and 96 percent sensitivity that
is compared to the cytotoxic
infiltration assay and the toxigenic
culture respectively specificity was
reported as 90 to 96 percent so I think
it's fair to say that the gdh is
slightly less sensitive but overall is
is a very good and sensitive asset
I think it's also important to remember
that gdh assays are less expensive as a
screening assays and some if not all
molecular assays which are traditionally
more expensive and of course by the
nature of the technology molecular
assays are more sensitive and specific
when used in direct testing so in terms
of the conclusion samples that test
positive by either direct molecular
assay or gdh enzyme immunoassay both
should be retested for toxin a and b to
confirm or increase the likelihood of
active Clostridium difficile infection
itself it is not recommended that any
test via gdh or NAT test be used singly
or as an independent test the key is to
detect toxin because the toxin is what
drives the disease process with regards
to the toxins themselves as I indicated
there toxin a theirfox and B of the two
toxin B is the primary player it is the
one it's responsible for the disease
process toxin a is a secretory toxin
that I described as it opens the door in
the colonic epithelium to allow the
entrance and the activity of the toxin B
but when we talk about molecular methods
there's actually two different
approaches which I've listed there on
the slide for you the PCR nucleic acid
amplification ie the Nats and then loop
mediated isothermal application Luke
mediated isothermal application detects
toxin a which has been shown to be a
good predictor of toxin B being
president most of the toxin tests are
targeting toxin B remember that the
molecular assays detect the gene the
gene
is producing or programming toxigenic
c.difficile it does not detect the toxin
I think another thing that we have to
remember here is that when we talk about
laboratory assays we're referring to
analytical metrics sensitivity
specificity predicted value etc that is
independent of the clinical metrics
clinical sensitivity in other words the
laboratory is strictly independent of
the patient condition whereas the
clinical is highly dependent on the
clinical presentation of the patient
thus molecular assays in general have of
low clinical specificity you could also
build a case for that for some of your
conventional testing as well we go to
the next slide comments on the
laboratory study design and I'll tell
you upfront we favor an algorithmic
based testing approach we introduced
that approximately five years ago and
that's the study design involves
algorithmic based testing so if you
would focus your attention on the slide
and here we have beginning the
consistency of the specimen it is very
important that we restrict testing to
liquid stools now everyone knows that
diarrhea and itself has several causes
of which I will discuss towards the end
of our presentation but what we're
saying is a liquid stool that conforms
to the shape of the container as most of
you know there is a scoring system known
as the Bristol scoring system some labs
do use the Bristol scoring system to
assess the consistency of the stool to
determine that specimens eligibility for
testing it
is anywhere from one to seven those
laboratories that use a Bristol scoring
system and even in the literature will
test specimens a score of five six or
seven we do not follow the Bristol
scoring system instead we follow what I
call the Brecker test dr. Steve Becker
director of microbiology at the VA
Medical Center in Boston Massachusetts
and essentially he says that that ain't
loose it's of no use and more formally
the stick tests that we utilize baseball
and dr. breads recommendations are
simply this we put a stick applicator
stick or something of that pipe into the
stool and to quote dr. Brecker if the
stick stands the test is ban
if the stick falls test them all so for
test outs ability to test this stick
must fall once again we do use the
two-step algorithm in which PCR is use
as a confirmatory test
thus the three-step method if you will
so briefly in our algorithmic based
testing where we do a combination
glutamate dehydrogenase plus a toxin EIA
some of the outcomes that you can see
there based upon for example gdh
positive in toxin positive in our
in-house testing we would not do any
further confirmatory testing it is sent
out as positive with a comment likely to
have C difficile disease for our
evaluation purposes we tested all stools
independent of the tonton assay with the
diya Soren direct assay a specifically
the simplex of C difficile direct assay
and at that time we're also looking at
the infinity produced by Cepheid C
difficile assay which I indicated
earlier is one of those matter of fact
the only system
that not only detects the toxins that we
refer to but also the binary toxin so
put C D H positive positive in our
in-house testing though no further
testing if it's GD H positive toxin
positive molecular assays are used for
peace or confirmatory testing if it's GD
H negative which will occur you need to
look out for this but toxin positive we
confirm once again with PCR
it's rare incidents but it does occur
and of course if it's GD H negative and
toxic negative no additional testing is
performed and as a result of that it's
set out as C difficile test negative
unlikely to have C C difficile disease
so our molecular assays are in house had
been for a couple years of the Great
Basin system and it was used in this
particular evaluation as I indicated the
expert infinity by Cepheid and the
primary focus of course was to determine
the performance of the simplex ax C
difficile direct assay produced by the
deer soren company once again all
specimens were tested or direct PCR
involving the the asourian technology as
well as the infinity let's move to the
next slide
I seem to be having a problem with
moving my slides here we go what you're
looking at there is what used to be
called the integrated cycler produced
ideas so are now referred to as the
liaison MDX this is the instrument upon
which c.difficile testing is conducted
and briefly it is a user-friendly
apparatus and I'll briefly go through
the steps in using the assay you simply
dip the swab into the stool specimen
removed the excess by trimming or
pressing against the container you swirl
the swab into a sample prep buffer and
then dispose of the swab followed by
scanning the simplex reaction mix the
direct application disk as well as the
patient ID into the computer that
accompanies the system step two is a
process of pipetting where you take the
disk which to me looks somewhat like a
record and you lift the foil and unseal
the wells if you will followed by
pipetting directly your reaction mixture
into the designated well designated as
the our well that's the reaction well
and then pipette your stool specimen in
the buffer into the sample well those
wells are then sealed and the remaining
or the excess is torn off and once again
you're ready to place the application
disk into the MDX system
close the lid program the instrument and
within about an hour or less you will
have a result computer assisted computer
printouts are very simple minimal
hands-on time we determine around five
minutes or less hands-on depends on of
course the technologist but it is
user-friendly and
hands-on time is minimal much like its
counterparts in the molecular world I I
should share with you some limitations
of this evaluation but once again the
next slide will show you the algorithmic
approaches diffused in this laboratory
and as a result of this it's pretty
simplified how we report and etc so as a
result of that it is an algorithmic
based system when we talk about our test
results next slide I want to share with
you when I consider the limitations of
this evaluation I think is important to
remember it was a evaluation it was not
an intense in-depth research study so
some of the limitations for this
evaluation was that our overall sample
size was small it was below what I
considered the appropriate size to have
an effective and reliable statistical
analysis we did not use a comparator or
gold standard in other words we do not
use toxigenic culture or cell
cytotoxicity nor did we look at the
histology results on the patient so to
biopsy had been sent for the observation
of pseudo membranes we did not do any
risk analysis or risk likelihood to be
more selective in patient held ability
for testing in other words we tested all
samples that met the stick test we did
not investigate patient history to us we
did not know if the patient was on
laxatives especially laxatives used
within the last 48 hours we did not have
any antibiotic history all of which can
of course be associated with the
production of diarrhea
so if we examine the data keep in mind
that the great basin was our primary
in-house system where we compared
everything the simplex expert infinity
to our in-house algorithmic approach and
so in essence we had a total of a
hundred and ninety-six specimens that
were being eligible for testing under
the results section you can see the
testing outcome for each potential
result beginning with GD H and toxin
respectively being positive there are a
total of 11 and of course under the
Great Basin they would not have been
tested and would have been reported out
as positive but as I indicated we tested
all specimens direct with the respective
molecular assays the simplex and the
Infinity in the next category you can
see that there were 25 incidents where
the EIA testing GD H was positive that
toxin was negative thus those require
confirmatory testing by a molecular
assay in this case PCR note that there
were 25 glutamate dehydrogenase
positives also bear in mind a GD H
glutamate dehydrogenase does not
discriminate between sport producing and
vegetative strains this antigen is
common to both strains sport producers
as well as vegetative strains both will
express as I indicated earlier
extracellular gdh you'll note that there
were 15 detected as positive by the
simplex a--
as well as by the infinity now the
infinity also detected one additional
positive versus a simplex so the 15 had
more
tected by the simplex versus sixteen by
the Infinity leaving ten that were
negative by both Great Basin and simplex
versus the nine by infinity so how do we
explain these findings keep in mind that
molecular tests detect toxigenic strains
only therefore the respective negative
nucleic acid testing results versus the
25 budda mate dehydrogenase results
suggest that those specimens that were
negative by that carried the
nontoxigenic strain of c difficile once
again toxigenic strains are what is
detected by our molecular assays not the
nontoxigenic strain these patients could
also have had been asymptomatic and
simply colonized which does occur in
hospitalized patients or they could have
had diarrhea due to other causes we do
know that patients with positive toxin
results have a higher likelihood of
having C difficile infection clinically
and does require therapy versus those
patients who are negative for toxin that
yet test positive for the toxigenic C
difficile they tune the further clinical
evaluation to distinguish incidental C
difficile colonization from truly active
CDI I should also bring to light that
there is yet to be determined and agreed
upon formal definition of true
clustering and difficile infection I
think it's important for us to remember
you will note an incidence where we had
one GD h-
and toxin positive as I said that's a
rare occurrence but it does occur so in
this particular case both the great
basin the simplex node and the infinity
all picked up the toxigenic strains so
the toxin was positive and a possible
explanation for this is that the
negative GD H resulted or was most
likely do that the the level or organism
load was below the sensitivity of the
assay due to once again the likelihood
of a very low concentration C difficile
and it's a does to once again reinforce
the fact that molecular assays are far
more sensitive than non molecular assays
in most cases when this type of result
occurs that is a GD H negative it's not
uncommon for the D toxin to be negative
as you indicated as I indicated here
our toxin was positive so as a result of
that we could have encountered the
situation where the level of GD H was
simply below the sensitivity of the GD h
assay those are possible explanations
for dis fighting but once again to
reiterate and you will encounter that
type of result and that's why
confirmatory testing is critical overall
you can see there were 159 negatives by
toxin and GD H analysis and 157 of those
were detected as negative by the simplex
versus 156 by the infinity so we're
these false positives there's no way
that we can really tell without having
done further testing with either
toxigenic culture or the cell
cytotoxicity near
civilization si I think this points out
that we need to be more selective also
in an hour and what patients are
eligible for testing in other words we
should limit our testing to only those
patients that have the highest
likelihood for C difficile disease be
more selective rather than test simply
all specimens that come in from patients
that are regarded as having diarrhea so
in our efforts to promote appropriate
utilization of our C difficile testing
we encourage physicians to not
automatically order testing on every
patient with diarrhea which as you know
can be associated with such things as
tube feeding diabetes and as I mentioned
earlier of course laxatives so today
this was after the evaluation was done
infection control in the laboratory and
it's team approach to promoting
appropriate utilization developed a
checklist and that checklist basically
determines whether or not that specimen
is going to be eligible for testing for
c difficile Riegert reviewed by nursing
and that's submitted with the specimen
to the laboratory
once again reviewed by the testing
technologist and if it meets the
established criteria it is tested if it
does not it is automatically rejected I
think something else that we need to
take into consideration and we make an
effort although it's an extra step we'd
like to know some additional criteria
regarding the patient with regards to
the likelihood c difficile for example
some of the clinical criteria that are
utilized or recommended are greater than
or equal to three liquid stools per day
that is regarded as clinically
significant diarrhea an elevated white
count
that's another indication because the
toxin B is responsible for the disease
process and with that you obtain white
cells and etc another indication is
creatinine specifically a cramping level
that's one and a half times the baseline
of that patient and if albumin is
decreased that's another indication we
also like to know if there's been a
history of antibiotic use within the
last 30 days and if possible is there
any evidence of pseudo membranes fall in
colonoscopy let's go to the next slide
with regards to overall agreement and
performance of the simplex F C difficile
direct assay it compares very favorably
with our in-house tests and compared
favorably with the infinity as well both
were very good the overall accuracy as
you can see there it was 98.5 percent
but note at the bottom of the table the
false positives I alluded to earlier
even though the incidence is very low
this would require further testing with
either cytotoxicity neutralization assay
or toxigenic cultures I indicated we did
not do that so as a result of that we
could say that the simplex the c
difficile direct assay is a suitable
assay for use in algorithmic testing if
we go to the next slide current
guidelines the only in-depth guideline
currently available in the literature
for c difficile testing management and
so forth is that published by the
Europeans by girl Bach and others in the
clinical microbiology and infection
listed there on the slide it's a very
good in-depth guideline for review and
consideration they do recommend
algorithmic testing but once again you
can make a case
for either direct PCR or algorithmic
based testing and at the recent ASM
microbe dr. Perik Fang took the point
and presented very good data regarding
the value of direct PCR whereas the
european group build a very good case
for the algorithmic based testing we as
i indicated earlier adopted the
algorithmic based testing approach and
have been very happy with it in addition
to the checklist that are now required
to be completed by the clinicians
reviewed by nursing and etc to ensure
that the test meets eligibility
requirements should let you know that
the American Society for Microbiology is
in the process of writing an
evidence-based medicine laboratory
guideline for C difficile where we
looked at over 8,000 papers
develop stringent criteria for inclusion
etc won't bore you with the details but
that manuscript is currently being
written it is our hope that that
manuscript will be published in the
clinical microbiology reviews in the
spring of next year
IDSA also has guidelines but they're
more focused on therapy infection
control not so much on diagnostic
testing so once again there is some
literature there and it is available and
I encourage in addition to the other two
papers that I highlight at the beginning
presentation I would encourage you to
look at those next slide just a kind of
an overview of advantages and
limitations of C difficile testing
methods most of you are totally familiar
with this I won't go into great detail
but in general your molecular assays are
highly sensitive some would say they
have a tendency to over call
c.difficile and in our value-based
purchasing today reimbursement is a big
issue and it's very very important that
this data indicate true indication of
the prevalence in an institution because
these as you know the Public Health and
the CDC require that these be reportable
so knowing the prevalence of C difficile
infection in your institution is very
very important because it does impact on
reimbursement so the molecular assays
obviously are very rapid about an hour
and a half they're expensive and but
they detect the gene and do not detect
toxin so you cannot with direct PCR
differentiate colonization carriage and
etc or active disease and therefore that
builds or indicates why clinical
specificity is very low does a tendency
to inflate your C difficile infection
rates in your institution moving through
the gdh and other enzyme immunoassays
as I said the gdh is modestly less
sensitive and many of the molecular
assays as well as toxin assays toxin
tests also are less sensitive but once
again it's very important to understand
when using combination you're likely to
obtain a positive result the toxin test
as I indicated being less sensitive in
toxigenic culture primarily this could
be due to z for example the toxigenic
assay culture SAS is designed to detect
the toxigenic strain the toxin test is
designed to test or detect the toxin so
toxin tests are generally less sensitive
than the toxigenic culture this could be
due to a degradation of toxin in the
specimen during transport
or it could be due to prolonged storage
freezing of the stool prior to testing
could be a risk factor for degrading and
compromising the detection of toxin or
you may have a methodological problems
so once again the GD H and EIA
combinations for toxin a and B are rapid
yes they are less expensive than the
molecular assays as I reinforce the GD H
is believed to piss about 20% of
positives that were detected by
molecular assays in patients that
actually have symptomatic or confirm or
true CDI but a negative test I think
it's is very important does not rule out
see the ISO further testing is still
required obviously our recommendation is
algorithmic testing where we use a
combination of EIA specifically GD H and
toxin a and B with using molecular
assays or not as a confirmatory
especially in those situations where the
enzyme immunoassay for toxin a and B or
negative and there's a very very two
good papers that are listed for you
which I alluded to earlier let's go to
the next slide so by way of summary
there was a very acceptable and complete
agreement between the dinosaur on
simplexity
C difficile direct assay and the expert
affinity in comparison with our two step
or three steps outer rhythm is in house
so the overall agreement as I indicated
earlier but needs to be mentioned with
very very good and the simplex assay
compare very favorably to the expert
infinity in addition to our in-house
testing and the simplex assay is a
reliable method for using it as a
confirmatory test in those laboratories
that follow algorithmic
testing strategy next test slide rather
I'm sorry once again to re-emphasize
point that single standalone test or
discouraged they indicated we recommend
algorithmic testing but if you read both
of those papers you can decide what is
best for your institution so the
two-stage is once again involves gdh and
toxin or you could start out with the
molecular assay and if it's positive
then do a toxin AIA either way you could
report that CDI I if they are negative
is unlikely whereas positive results
where the toxin PIAA has been shown to
be positive or you confirm that toxin is
present you can report out that the
likely or CDI is likely so if we go to
number two there for the GD h e I a is
positive and the toxin a and B e ia both
are positive would report out at C D
eyes likely present if both are negative
CDI is unlikely and once again if your
GD H is positive and your toxin a and B
is negative you simply can confirm with
either a toxigenic culture or nucleic
acid assay next slide I'd like to
acknowledge Gina Thompson
she is our research technologist who
conducted this evaluation and also of
course want to thank Dias or molecular
for providing the reagents and supplies
to allow us to do this I would also like
to mention that every effort I think we
have a goal or should have a similar
goal that we really need to make every
effort to limit clustering difficile
testing in low risk populations in other
words focus only on the high-risk
population
this augments or influences predicted
values of diagnostic test and if you do
it in a low-risk population it also
reduces the misdiagnosis of CDI who in
patients are actually carriers of
Australian difficile and really do not
have clinically significant diarrhea the
diarrhea due to other causes in addition
to the sources are causing the diarrhea
I mentioned earlier some others include
inflammatory bowel disease recent
abdominal surgery and viral illness
there are others but these are some of
the more common ones we get in the next
slide I want to take this opportunity to
thank you and will now be available to
take questions
thank you dr. Schneider for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A if you have a question you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
questions we will follow them up via
email after the presentation let's get
started our first question is would it
be useful to detect patients who are
colonized with C difficile but do not
have active CDI can the Cleary's infect
other patients in a hospital well that
question relates to should we or should
we not do active surveillance for c
difficile for example patients that are
admitted to the hospital that is a
question that can only be answered by
infection control in combination and
infectious diseases and I think you need
to involve administration because of the
cost involved but once again that is I
think in part based upon or would be
influenced by the current prevalence of
true
C difficile infection in the institution
the surveillance it is a way to identify
those patients and this infects
infection control in terms of managing
these patients did we put them in
isolation and etc all of which from the
administrative perspective have costs
associated with them so it really has to
be determined through a consensus
between the infection control and
prevention personnel infectious disease
administration and the laboratory should
be involved in that as well thank you
for that answer our next question is is
antibiotic resistance an issue for seeds
episome antibiotic resistance currently
is very very low I anticipate or likely
to see that increase as we use more and
more antibiotics especially in
individuals who may be asymptomatic that
are carriers we need to remember that
this is a big challenge for clinicians
when they get a laboratory test result
back and if that laboratory test result
is positive by a molecular assay they
have a tendency to treat independent of
the patient's clinical condition we
sometimes say that the challenge results
in the physician treating the laboratory
result not the patient so once again
resistance by selective pressure is very
potential as we use more and more
antibiotics but once again currently
resistance is not a problem or a serious
problem as a result of that I would have
to say we need to track resistance rate
and maybe at some point in time do
surveillance by saving our isolates and
doing susceptibility testing using a
reputable
taury that is experienced in doing
susceptibility testing to organisms such
as c difficile thank you
our next question is what is the kind of
treatment guideline for c difficile
infections well once again the clinical
presentation I discussed earlier three
or more liquid stools per day increased
white count the one and a half times
baseline with grabbing and a decrease in
Allegan are pretty good indicators
potential from C difficile infection but
as I said earlier there has yet to be an
agreed-upon formal definition of what or
related to true C difficile infection so
those clinical criteria that we have
currently are are our most reliable
indicators at least consider C difficile
and submit the appropriate specimen for
testing thank you for that answer our
next question is what are the turnaround
times for the three molecular assays
such as great basin infinity and
complexity every turnaround time for the
test is one and a half hours it looks
like we have time for one more question
our last question is how long does GD h
plus toxin CIA a sated to perform is
this a lab develop acid could you repeat
that question please yes our last
question is how long does the GD h plus
toxin at they take to perform is this a
lab develop a say well these are
commercially available assays they were
originally glass developed the test time
at least in our hands is approximately
30 to 45 minutes so it's equivalent to
the molecular assays but at the same
time
you're detecting two different targets
as opposed to one with the molecular
assay I would like to once again thank
dr. Schneider for his presentation do
you have any final comments well I think
we need to appreciate I'm sure most of
the participants do the seriousness of C
difficile disease the huge expenditure
that is associated with Clostridium
difficile and the fact that we need
appropriate testing as well as
utilization of testing by that I mean
when the order C difficile testing based
upon the clinical appearance of the
patient and to work with clinicians in
terms of educating them in terms of the
limitations as well as the advantages of
these respective assays once again I
still believe that the key is
demonstrating toxin because toxin is the
driver of disease the absence of toxin
once again is challenging but it's a
clinical diagnosis that only the
physician can make and hopefully working
in conjunction with the laboratory so we
have a we have a major challenge before
us is to clearly define and agree upon
what is true CDI or pas stream difficile
infection and are we going to be in a
position where we can select specimens
for testing based upon risk or
likelihood and try to confine those
tests to those patients that most likely
will have C difficile infection rather
than test everybody so we have a lot of
work ahead of us thank you thank you
once again dr. Schneider I would also
like to thank lab roots MD a soaring for
making today's educate
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
to December 14 2017 you will receive an
email from labyrinth letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share the announcements
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye